We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. that no language on earth has ever produced the expression as pretty as an airport. Airports are ugly, some very ugly. Some attain a degree of ugliness that can only be the result of a special effort. This ugliness arises because airports are full of people who are tired,
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内进行合作与创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。地球上没有任何语言能创造出像“机场”这样优美的表达。机场很丑，有些非常丑。有些丑陋程度达到了某种境界，只能是刻意为之的结果。这种丑陋之所以产生，是因为机场里挤满了疲惫的人，
cross, and have just discovered that their luggage has landed in Mamanck. Mamanck airport is the only exception of this otherwise infallible rule, and architects have on the whole try to reflect this in their designs. From Douglas Adams, the long dark tea time of the saw. I think so many airports were not designed for the things that they have to do right now, and so it is all fixing as you go. There wasn't some great master plan, so. So when it comes to the ugliness and general dysfunction of airports.
脾气暴躁，而且刚刚发现他们的行李落在了摩尔曼斯克。摩尔曼斯克机场是这一颠扑不破的规则中唯一的例外，建筑师们总体上试图在他们的设计中反映这一点。摘自道格拉斯·亚当斯的《长黑茶时间》。我认为很多机场的设计并没有考虑到它们现在必须承担的功能，所以一切都是边走边修。并没有什么伟大的总体规划。所以，当谈到机场的丑陋和普遍的功能失调时，
They're a little bit off the hook? A little bit off the hook, but there's plenty of room for improvement. When I spoke with Alison Ariaf about the design of airports, she said to me, if all airports simply played Brian Eno's album music for airports over the speakers, every airport would be better. My name is Alison Ariath and I read about design and sustainability for the New York Times. I say this to serve not only as an introduction to Alison Ariath, but also so that you'll
它们是否有点无可奈何？确实有点无可奈何，但仍有很大的改进空间。当我与艾莉森·阿里亚夫谈论机场设计时，她对我说，如果所有机场都能在扬声器里播放布莱恩·伊诺的《机场音乐》专辑，每个机场都会变得更好。我叫艾莉森·阿里亚夫，我为《纽约时报》撰写关于设计和可持续发展的文章。我这么说不仅是为了介绍艾莉森·阿里亚夫，也是为了让你
know that she is someone whose judgment is perfectly true. An architect I spoke to you said nothing is more quickly obsolete than an airport building. Like the technology is changing so fast. And the thing that all airports are still trying to catch up to now, the thing that forced airports to change the most the fastest was 9-11. Security screening has come to dominate all aspects of airport design, but we're going to focus on just two effects.
知道她是一个判断力极其精准的人。我采访过的一位建筑师说，没有什么比机场建筑过时得更快了。因为技术变化太快了。而所有机场现在仍在努力追赶的、迫使机场变化最快的事情就是“9·11”事件。安检已经主导了机场设计的方方面面，但我们只关注其中的两个影响。
The first is that because the unpredictability and time required to go through security, you no longer doodle on what is called the land side of the airport. Land side is basically the curb appeal part of the airport. Parking is still considered land side. The ticketing area is still considered landside. The wonderful lines that you have to wait in to TSA, which are also changing by the way. Most airports, of course, have had to make room for those lines, so all of that is landside. So once you wind yourself through the pleasant experience that is security, you are on the airside.
首先，由于安检的不可预测性和所需时间，你不再在所谓的机场“陆侧”闲逛。陆侧基本上是机场的门面部分。停车仍被视为陆侧。值机区域仍被视为陆侧。你必须排队等待安检的那些美妙队伍，顺便说一下，这些也在变化。当然，大多数机场都必须为这些队伍腾出空间，所以所有这些都是陆侧。因此，一旦你穿过了安检那段愉快的经历，你就进入了“空侧”。
The people responsible for building airports really kind of followed the bus station model where it was like a holding pen. We just got you here as long as we put you on Amtrak or put you on Greyhound and airports were sort of on that model too because the assumption was you were just passing through. Now the assumption is that you are absolutely not just passing through. The assumption is that you are going to be staying a while. So newer airports are designed with that in mind. And a good example of this new thinking described in a recent New York Times article by Ariav is the new T2 terminal designed by Gensler Architects at San Francisco International Airport. T2 is the new terminal for American Airlines and Virgin America at San Francisco International Airport.
负责建造机场的人实际上有点遵循了公交车站的模式，就像一个候车室。我们只是把你带到这里，只要把你送上美铁或灰狗巴士就行了，机场也采用了这种模式，因为假设你只是路过。现在，假设你绝对不仅仅是路过。假设你会停留一段时间。所以较新的机场在设计时就考虑到了这一点。阿里亚夫在最近的一篇《纽约时报》文章中描述的这种新思维的一个很好的例子，就是由根斯勒建筑事务所为旧金山国际机场设计的全新T2航站楼。T2是美国航空和维珍美国航空在旧金山国际机场的新航站楼。
And it's one of the first terminals to be designed to post 9-11. The last terminal constructed before T2 at SFO was the International Terminal that opened in December of 2000. It still feels pretty new, but you can tell right away that the trajectory of airport design was going in a very different direction in the year 2000 than what is prioritized today. Seven Cisco's main international terminal, for example, is all about the ticketing area you walk in. It's just this massive amount of space. It's open and airy and actually pretty wonderful to experience, but in the new world of TSA, all that building doesn't
它是第一批在“9·11”之后设计的航站楼之一。在T2之前，旧金山国际机场建造的最后一个航站楼是2000年12月启用的国际航站楼。它现在看起来仍然很新，但你可以立刻看出，2000年机场设计的轨迹与今天优先考虑的方向截然不同。例如，旧金山的主要国际航站楼，完全围绕着你走进来的值机区域。它拥有巨大的空间。它开阔、通风，体验起来其实相当美妙，但在TSA（美国运输安全管理局）的新世界里，所有这些建筑都
make any sense. If you actually sit and think about it, you realize that all the exciting stuff is on the land side. You're eating, you're shopping, etc. All that happens before security. In the new T2, all the good stuff is saved post-security because, as we all know, everyone's just rushing to their plane and they don't want to linger at all. So while there is a very generous, well-designed ticketing area, they've given way more square footage, like thousands and thousands of square feet, to what's called the airside, which is where the planes actually come into the gate. What's also different about T2 is that they're really incorporating the security procedures
毫无意义。如果你坐下来仔细想想，你会发现所有令人兴奋的事情都在陆侧。你在吃饭、购物等等。所有这些都发生在安检之前。在新的T2中，所有好的东西都留在了安检之后，因为众所周知，每个人都急着去登机，根本不想逗留。因此，虽然有一个非常宽敞、设计良好的值机区域，但他们把更多的平方英尺，即成千上万平方英尺的空间，留给了所谓的“空侧”，也就是飞机实际到达登机口的地方。T2的不同之处还在于，他们真正将安检程序纳入了
in the design from the get-go. When you look at security now, it often looks like the TSA just set up shop yesterday with retractable barriers and then it spits you out to a couple of folding chairs to put on your shoes and that stole your laptop. The new T2 actually has what they call a recompose zone which is like a lounge for putting your clothes back on after you get to TSA with you know some sculpture and lots of natural light and skylights and and once you are at that spot putting your shoes in your belt and you're jewelry and whatever else back on you can see everything that you're about to enter into retail gates
设计之初。当你现在看安检时，它看起来通常就像TSA昨天才刚设立的一样，有伸缩式护栏，然后把你吐到几把折叠椅上让你穿鞋，而那偷走了你的笔记本电脑。新的T2实际上有一个他们称之为“重组区”的地方，就像一个休息室，让你在通过TSA后重新穿上衣服，你知道，那里有一些雕塑、充足的自然光和天窗。一旦你到了那个地方，穿上鞋子、系好皮带、戴上首饰以及其他东西，你就可以看到你即将进入的所有零售店、登机口、
seating all that sort of stuff. I never give them much thought to shops or restaurants and airports but the thing I need not want what I need when I travel is it a place to plug in my phone or laptop and probably both. There are many, many more banks about Lens, because again, you think even back to pre-9-11, which is now just about 10 years ago, the ubiquity of personal technology was not, you know, there were walkmans, right? They didn't need to get plugged in. Now everyone's got something at every age,
座位等等。我以前从没太在意机场的商店或餐馆，但我在旅行时需要的东西——不是想要的，而是需要的——是一个可以给手机或笔记本电脑充电的地方，可能两者都需要。现在有更多更多的充电位，因为同样，即使回想“9·11”之前，也就是大约10年前，个人技术的普及程度并没有那么高，你知道，那时候有随身听，对吧？它们不需要插电。现在每个人，无论什么年龄，
every sort of traveling segment. So of course, older airports don't have enough. I was in a hair recently sitting on the floor next to this businessman, and we were huddled like hobos around this single outlet in this three gate area. 12 plus 12 leveling, one six stop. According to area, human factor studies shows that passengers want to stay within 250 feet
无论什么类型的旅行群体，都有电子设备。所以当然，老机场的插座不够用。我最近在机场，坐在一个商人旁边的地板上，我们像流浪汉一样蜷缩在这个三登机口区域的唯一一个插座旁。12加12平整，16停。根据阿里亚夫的说法，人类因素研究表明，乘客希望留在距离
of their gate, and T2 at SFO addresses this anxiety. If you're buying a paper, grabbing a coffee, sitting down at the restaurant, all of the gates are visible all the time because of the open floor plan. What I heard a lot in talking to many, many architects about airports is that at the top of the list is letting people feel the control of their experience and having a sense of where they're going. And really sort of designing so that all of the anxiety that comes naturally with that whole process now is alleviated to the greatest extent. And so a good sort of environments designer who can really into it where people's hang- are going to be. It's key to a successful project. The noble goal is to try to design a way all airport anxieties no matter how experienced
登机口250英尺以内，而旧金山机场的T2解决了这种焦虑。如果你在买报纸、喝咖啡、坐在餐馆里，由于开放式的平面布局，所有的登机口始终都在视野范围内。我在与许多建筑师谈论机场时听到最多的是，首要任务是让人们感受到对体验的掌控感，并知道他们要去哪里。真正进行设计，以便现在随整个过程自然产生的所有焦虑都能在最大程度上得到缓解。因此，一个好的环境设计师能够真正直觉地感受到人们的需求在哪里，这是项目成功的关键。崇高的目标是试图设计出消除所有机场焦虑的方法，无论
the traveler. But who knows, in 10 years I could be redoing the story and contrasting T2 against some new super airport that solves all the problems of usage that T2 failed to anticipate. There's no place to park my jetpack, fail. For anything complex, perfect design is a moving target. But odds are your luggage will still be in Mermatsk. 99% invisible was produced this week by me Roman Mars was support from lunar, making a difference with creativity.
旅客经验多么丰富。但谁知道呢，10年后我可能会重写这个故事，将T2与某个新的超级机场进行对比，那个机场解决了T2未能预见的所有使用问题。没有地方停放我的喷气背包，失败。对于任何复杂的事物，完美的设计都是一个移动的目标。但你的行李很可能还是会留在摩尔曼斯克。《99%隐形》本周由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了Lunar的支持，用创造力创造改变。
It's a project of KALW, 91.7 local public radio and San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. You can keep up with Alison Ariaf at the opinionator blog of the New York Times, and I should mention that the Douglas Adams quote with the top of the show was read by Francesca Panetta, who's the producer and creator of the Hackney podcast, which is consistently stunning and amazing and you should subscribe, although it does have a dearth of Francesca Panetta's voice in it. You've probably heard more of her here and you'll ever hear on the Hackney podcast.
这是KALW 91.7本地公共广播电台、旧金山美国建筑师协会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。你可以通过《纽约时报》的Opinionator博客关注艾莉森·阿里亚夫。我应该提到，节目开头引用的道格拉斯·亚当斯的语录是由弗朗西斯卡·帕内塔朗读的，她是Hackney播客的制作人和创作者，该播客一直令人惊叹，你应该订阅，尽管里面确实缺乏弗朗西斯卡·帕内塔的声音。你在这里听到的可能比你在Hackney播客上听到的还要多。
Thank you, Fran. To find out more and get all kinds of links, go to the website at 99personinvisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，弗兰。欲了解更多信息并获取各种链接，请访问网站 99personinvisible.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。